i hope everyone's excited it is now
september 2nd
we are now in the ninth month of the
second year of the pandemic
we are still virtual obviously here we
were hoping that we would be in person
by september
but we all had that little forest three
weeks of summer and then everyone went
back to uh back to lockdown so i hope
everyone's excited so we have people
from all around the world when we do
return to in person whenever that may be
we will continue with the virtual
portion now that we've learned how to do
it better than we used to before the
pandemic we tried live streaming the
meetups but the audio never quite worked
out but now that we can just throw zoom
on the presenter's laptop we'll do
virtual again
once we resume to in person but i don't
know what a person is going to be we
just don't know when that's going to
happen depends when people feel
comfortable and when companies give us
space in their new york city offices
so
first thing i always like to do whenever
we start the meetups is say who is
hiring
now of course not everyone could jump up
on here in fact no one can jump up on
here really and say they're hiring
because no one else could be on screen
besides the three of us who are already
here so if you have a job that you're
looking to fill
you can go to the job postings channel
of the ny hacker slack i will throw up
the ny hacker slack in the chat here uh
the link to join the slack if you're not
a member remember already there's a job
posting channel post a job there if
you're looking to hire
go there if you're looking to get hired
there's a link for nyhacar.org
slack.html and beneath that is actually
the direct link to
um to the channel
since i am on the screen i will take
advantage of that and say that i am have
three open positions for open positions
we are hiring an account executive
a shiny developer
a r admin that's right an admins that
means like a linux system but
specializing in r
and a data scientist so if you're
interested in any of those roles working
for lander analytics
message me you can find me on slack you
can find me on twitter you can find me
at jerrylander.com atlanta analytics.com
many many ways to find me it's a very uh
very easy to find a way to get
attachment
so
i hope everyone has their favorite snack
i have pizza which we all know is a
mainstay to meet up and have some good
cheese lock there it's staying in place
even the basil staying in we have some
good charring for a wood burning oven
underneath it yes i did already get
started one slice that's why my bite is
taken out but i'm okay with that i
had to get started early because the
pizza came here a little earlier than i
expected
i already fed some of it to my son and
my wife they all got to eat pizza it was
amazing
so hope everyone has your favorite snack
in fact let us know where you got your
favorite snacks from in the chat in the
slack chat or in here let us know where
you get your snacks from hopefully pizza
but i respect people who want to eat
food that's not pizza i don't know why
you would but sure go for it
um so that's our pizza and of course we
can't be here in person i wish we could
be um we could all have pizza again do
the pizza but we haven't done the pizza
poll in like a year and a half and i'm
really sad we haven't collected more
data for that
hopefully soon
so
yesterday were the workshops for what is
now the seventh annual new york r
conference we had a lot of fun we had
max [ __ ] david robinson we had lucy
d'agostino and i always forget her lasso
second last name sorry lucy malcolm
barrett dan chen cat akimoto and euron
janssen's all teaching these great
workshops
so that means the conference takes place
next week this year we did the workshops
the week before trying something new we
had the meetup week before this week
so next week is the conference september
9th and 10th we have two full fun days
of r
at last month's meetup i was talking
about how excited we were for it to be
in person
but it's going to be virtual now
completely virtual we changed on a dime
we had a great team here and nicole who
was here in this meetup did a great job
pivoting to fully virtual we are sad we
weren't going to be there in person we
were sad we weren't going to eat all
that great food we had pizza and ice
cream and avocados planned we had these
great speakers coming we still have the
great speakers they're going to be
virtual and we're going to do
as much fun as we could have virtually
we've gotten good at this this will be
now our third conference between the new
york conference and the government
conference
we've gotten good at it so i hope to see
a lot of you there
uh if you would like to attend and you
haven't bought a ticket yet
there is a discount code for the meetup
because this conference
started seven years ago because i wanted
to take what we did with meet up one
hour a month and say let's do two full
days of it so this conference is really
meant for this meetup so you could use
code ny hack r
for a 20 discount
so you could get a chance to enjoy it
more
we are also running a diversity
scholarship for underrepresented groups
tomorrow is the last day to sign up for
it
there hopefully is going to be a link in
the chat because i don't remember the
link for it but if you are a member of
an underrepresented group you can go
that form fill it out to get a diversity
scholarship to attend
so go there fill it out come join us
as part of the conference the tradition
we started a few years ago we have an
art auction
and one of the artists is with us right
now jacqueline could you show us what
we'll be auctioning off
that's right um so i have here i have
made a print earlier this year of david
and goliath and this is the original it
was
stored in safety um and it's a gouache
11x14 and you can be the one and only
person who owns this and you raise money
for charity by buying it um
i'm very proud of it i think it'll look
good on any wall um
so there you go
that is really awesome i always get
jealous because i don't bid on anything
here because i think be weird if i want
a piece of art at my conference so i'm
always jealous of a great piece of art
one year actually the robinson siblings
they all bought me a piece of art i was
like like i brought a tear to my eye it
was amazing uh it was like it was like i
wanted it so badly it's um i don't have
it here it's like still at my new york
office hanging up where no one is it's
the only thing there in the office
anymore anyway our auction's gonna be
awesome and jacqueline mentioned it i
didn't the money is being donated to the
r foundation i think that's the cause we
can all get behind here um that's where
we're going to send the money to so come
for the art auction you can go there
right now the link is in the chat
so for today's meetup we obviously can't
ask questions of jacqueline directly
because that just doesn't work right so
i'm going to ask everyone to ask your
questions either in the zoom chat that's
right here um you can ask it right in
there or in slack there is a channel
called monthly meetup chat very
appropriately named go there for
questions or just chatting let us know
we got your pizza from there or your
non-pizza let us know what's in there
and ask questions there at the end of
the talk i will collate the questions
and i will ask them with jacqueline and
jacqueline lancer i hope unless you
refuse to answer i don't know why
you never know
so with that we have our questions being
asked there we have the conference next
week we are super excited and we will
announce oh by the way we will announce
the october meetup as soon as we get
that scheduled things are thrown a
little haywire because we're not going
to be in person it seems so we're going
to get that schedule and announce it
within the next few weeks sometime after
the conference because that's our focus
for the next week all right with that
everyone i'm very excited as a past
conference speaker i've known jacqueline
for many years now actually it's been
quite a long time so everyone please
welcome jacqueline for very exciting
talk i'm gonna give you a little virtual
applause
okay thank you
loud crowd um okay so let me share my
screen and we'll get started um
cool i'm assuming you can all see my
screen um i'm gonna do one or two
minor things here with the zoom
and away we go so um like okay before we
even start getting a talk let's
it's thursday night we're about to have
a long weekend you know the last thing
we all want to do is sit here and go
through a very formal talk of very
serious stuff so we're gonna let's kick
it back for like 45 minutes and let's
just have some fun and we're going to
talk about a fun thing tonight which is
being ridiculous and in fact in
particular what we're going to talk
about
is about that time i made an entire
ecommerce platform in shiny shiny was
not designed or was not necessarily
built to the intention of using for
e-commerce but i found a way to do it
and for the next 45 minutes or whatever
um
i will talk to you about all the sort of
uh things that went into that and some
um antics that ensued because of it and
the ultimate result
so to start what is ggirl
ggirl is an e-commerce platform that was
made in shiny by me hence the talk uh
but in particular what does dgirl do
well if you notice like there's so many
good g plot two plots out there that
people make right you see on twitter
these beautiful plots even the
accidental art is actually quite pretty
um so they're always cool plots out
there but they're all stuck on computer
screens and i find this to be a problem
i think art should exist in the physical
realm not just the electronic realm and
i was thinking about this and i was
thinking about different ways one could
make art from gg plot twos into real
life and eventually with brainstorming
help from other people including um
heather nolis i came up with the idea or
i got to the idea of um gg irl which is
a gg or an r package that will take your
gg plot and turn it into things in the
physical realm so for instance you can
take your gg plot and order it as a
postcard as shown below and so you run a
function
and it turns it in two weeks you will
get a postcard or your friends or
whoever will get these postcards
um you can order art prints and you can
order watercolors um these things cost
money to print and so i am not a charity
i'm not the r charity i require payment
so i can go do these which meant that
somehow i needed to make an r package
that actually got money from you and to
date i think this might be the only
package that i know of that is built in
financial transfers as part of it um
which is a new exciting frontier in
capitalism um
and so that's neat um and you can
actually use this package right now at
github.comggirl and it has lots of
detailed instructions on how to use it
as you can see there on the left is a
ggplot2 i made and on the right is the
postcard that got sent to me of it um
sitting on my post or on my mailbox
um you can also see here there's gg
postcard function to order a postcard
you can order an art print so there are
three
art prints over there on the left all
made from ggplot2 you can order them in
11 inches by 14 inches portrait and
landscape you can order them all the way
up to 24 inches by 36 inches that if you
think about it is enormous um and you
can order that from r
then on the right is gigi watercolor the
latest function in the family of gg irl
functions which is you take a ggplot and
i will paint it as a watercolor for you
as a custom commission which is neat um
you can actually see the picture in the
center on the left is what i water
colored on the right um you have a gg
plot i'll paint it for you
but for most of this talk uh let's
assume we're talking about the postcard
version of this function we'll talk
about the other ones at the end but like
they're all mostly the same with a few
twists and i think the postcard one is
the most technically interesting so
let's talk about that so the idea that
you run our code and then eventually a
postcard ends up somewhere with an image
on it
wild um
so the easiest way to start explaining
it is to just show a demo of it so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to open up
rstudio and i have some pre-written
lines of code i'm going to do a special
option because i want to run the dev
version because i don't want to pay for
a postcard i don't want to put my credit
card information in front of you
um but basically what you do is you
install you you open up ggplot2 and
ggirl and then first let's just make
some generic plot
there's my plot on the left or on the
right
directions am i right uh there's my plot
on the right it's not very interesting
but it is technically a gg plot assume
you could make a more interesting one
when using this package
there are examples available too if you
want some ideas so then you give the
contact email address so i know where to
send like the confirmation email to the
message you want on the postcard the
address to send that postcard to
and you take all of those
and then here's the magic
you run this
function gg postcard with those
parameters
and so it's thinking
um
and then actually this is really
interesting what's happening right here
is the shiny server that i'm using isn't
fully online yet so the package is like
uh oh the server isn't online yet let's
just wait 10 seconds and try it again
this is because i haven't tested it
right before the demo right before this
talk so i mean let's hope this works oh
good it looks like it's working great
and so now it brings us to a web page
this webpage shows that image
ready to be on a postcard
it gives you a little bit of details
around it it shows you what the message
is on the back and the address it's
sending it to this is a table because
you could send multiple postcards at
once if you're sending out say or like
baby uh birth notifications which
someone once did on this package which
is really cool um
you can also have different custom
messages for each of the addresses
you're going to so like you could
customize that a fair bit um but anyways
this is a a shiny web page which has
exactly one button on it pay and submit
so you hit pay and submit and it brings
you to stripe
i do not own an operate stripe stripe on
stripe you can see the url is now a
stripe one so somehow i managed to get
the user from shiny to stripe and with
the correct payment information in here
and so this is the test mode so i can
put in the fake credit card because i
don't want you guys to have my credit
card which is four two four two i'm
going to make up a fake month and year
uh a fake code my name's going to be
jane knowles my address is going to be
here
in seattle
i'm going to 2. it correctly calculates
tax which is neat and then i hit pay
it's thinking
and then
ding
it goes back and it says successor gg
order has been placed
ggirl order has been placed um
by the way ggirl stands for
gg plots in real life it's not g girl
that's a common debate anyway so now
we're back on shiny and then if i open
up my email
i should if i accidentally typed in the
right email address yeah i have an order
confirmation so that order confirmation
in it has that postcard image has that
address
and if i actually paid money in one to
two weeks i would get a physical
postcard with me now if i were clever i
would have held one right up and say it
looks exactly like this but somehow
in this giant set of drawers is all of
the examples i've made and i can't find
them but assume i'm holding a physical
postcard of what it looks like and
you're all impressed wow that's a lot
that's done with shiny
um okay so
that's the demo let's get back to the
talk
so a lot just happened and let's talk
about that so there are actually two
totally distinct components here one is
gg irl which is the r package that i use
to interface with a server and then
there's the back end which is ggrl
server which does everything else it
does that shiny preview it does the
stripe stuff it does sending the
postcard and the packet and the um the
email confirmation uh so all of that's
handled by a different thing you may ask
why couldn't i just done this all as one
package could i have done that all
locally
it's like well if i did that then you
probably could have like hacked it you
know if i did it all on the client side
then you could have hacked it and like
automatically sent things on so like i
needed a server to like manage this
stuff and so that created two components
the server which is a complicated thing
and the ggrl package which is the thing
you install on your computer which is
actually fairly simple comparatively
so before we go too deep into the rest
of the talk we're going to start talking
about http requests um they're going to
show up a lot in this talk and they're
really important they're also i think
way simpler than people have made them
out to be and um
frankly when i once i finally understood
http requests i was upset with software
developers for making them sound more
complicated than they actually were for
like decades of my career um
so when you go to a website or you use
an api
the vast majority of the times these use
http protocols and at the end of the day
a http
protocol is just like your browser
requesting sending a text file request
to a server and the text the server
sending a text file response back that
is the vast majority of internet traffic
really if you go to google.com that is
your browser sending a quick text
request to google server saying hey send
me the home page and then google sending
back one text file which is the html of
that page and now when you load that in
the browser your browser may say oh this
actually requires other stuff and go
pull more things but at its core it's
still one text sent text received
http has a couple different protocols
for different types of requesting and
sending data so a get request is like
literally like what a browser does it's
just going to a web page getting a text
response a post request is slightly more
complicated it is just it's like a get
request but you send data with it so um
like if you are going to you know if
you're on a web page and you you you're
filling out a form and you hit submit
that is your browser sending a post
request because you are going to that
webpage you are sending the response and
the response is all the things you
filled out on that web page or if you
upload something on a web page you are
generally sending a post request with
the image you upload or whatever so a
post is just like a get but with um
information
attached to it there are a bunch of
other ones but like those are two
important ones get in post
um
you can send these http requests
yourself besides using a browser which
does http request you can use the hitter
package or you can use tools like
postman or curl and so right at the
bottom here i have just some examples of
http requests um with hitter
so like going doing the get request to
google.com this is literally the exact
same thing as browsing on your browser
if you run that r code you will get a
big ugly html file back that is the
exact same file your browser gets back a
post is slightly more complicated
because it just has a body which is like
either a text string or a file or
something but it's like a get but just
with data attached to it i'm going way
into this because it's going to come up
a lot for the rest of this talk
um
you can also send the request to
different places and different things
happen so like if you do a get to like
whatever your shiny app doc you know
your your app.com
18 that's usually like going to a
website and getting the 18th photo of
the user and then slash photo 27 maybe
you'll get the 27th post uh photo of
that user so the idea is like the url
you go to after the domain so like your
app.com slash the rest of the stuff like
the slash the rest of the stuff is you
telling the server like what in
particular do you want
when you send that text request and get
it back
um
anything interactive on a web page is
different right like like you know on
shiny you got all these widgets things
around that's all javascript and
javascript is like after that http
request happens javascript is then doing
more things but that's like a whole
separate
line of reasoning
um but then importantly the r up shiny
when you interact with a shiny app what
you are doing is the shiny server is
running you are making a get request to
that page it returns the html and like
you know in the shiny app you have like
a ui component that is you specifying
what the what the html is and then you
use javascript to say okay but i want to
continue and to interact with the server
on the back end and then the shiny app
you also specify what the server back
end is doing
um
so you can actually receive so you can
send http requests with hitter you can
listen and receive htb requests in like
primarily two ways with r one is with
shiny shiny is great because it does
lots of this html and javascript
designing for you it's got this great ui
but at its core shiny is just something
that listens to just get requests so
shiny is only when a browser goes to a
web page
and listens for that there aren't ways
to do the other on their face there's
not ways to do the other kinds of
requests with shiny it's just for
browsers going to a server and getting
like a web page back and on its face a
shiny app can only have one url it's
generally like your shinyapp.com there's
not like your shiny app.com
part one of the app slash part two slash
photos videos it's just kind of one
thing
on its face
plumber
is
um more api focus so it handles not just
get requests but post requests whatever
different types of requests shiny has
that natively built in um
or sorry plummer has that natively built
in plumber does not have any of that
html pretty stuff with like javascript
and blah blah it really is just handling
these http like text response getting
them and sending back texts or like an
image file or a json file or whatever
but like one block of
information um
so there's like on its face there's no
like javascript and plumber you could if
you were really working at it you could
make plumber like actually send back
html files that connect to javascript
and actually like create shiny within
plumber do not do that that is not a fun
set of things to do but you could
um
and plumber has the feature that plumber
is like natively built in to have lots
of endpoints so you could have like your
plumber app.com photo video whatever
um
and plumber is a super cool r app if you
haven't used it before really do try it
because it's super easy to create lots
of these r endpoints so for instance if
you wanted to make it so if you go to a
particular url with a get request it'll
do a sum for you you can just in r write
a function to compute a sum of two
numbers and then make a plumber a
wrapper around it to say hey listen uh
listen to this for this function as an
http request and then if you went to
that bro that url to do several slash
one slash sum with these two parameters
it would return the result as an api so
there's all sorts of reasons why you'd
want to use this for like if you have a
model and you want another service to
run the model with a certain sense of
information
um
this slide came from uh for the last two
in real life r studio comps me and
heather nolis spoke on behalf of
t-mobile about all the cool stuff you
can do with r in production and plumber
and i highly recommend you we have a
blog post series about this we have
those two talks they're really cool you
should really check them out plumber is
really powerful for this http stuff
so given that let's go back to ggirl
what is the correct
correct architecture of ggirl so here's
how i think ggirl should work
which is on your computer when you're in
r and you say here's a ggplot2 plot i
want to send as a postcard
take the the package should take that
image and send it as a post request to
our server thing and because on its face
plumber is the thing that can handle
post requests we should have a plumber
listener that takes that post request
say cool i got the image i'm going to
save it and then i'm going to tell you
here's the id of that image i'm going to
pass it back to you and then the ggrl
package says okay i got that image i'm
going to go to that url i'm going to
view that shiny app shiny will then pass
you to stripe stripe will collect your
payment stripe will say hey you paid me
money i'm gonna go
send the application the knowledge that
we send it so i'm gonna send a post
request to this application and then
plumber because it handle posts listen
to that and then plumber will send a
post request to the sending a postcard
service and we'll order the postcards
so that's in theory the correct way to
do this but
that requires two plumber apps to run
plus a shiny app plus we might have to
have a different shiny app for each one
of these like postcards um art prints
watercolors so now we're talking like
three shiny apps and two polymer apis
and i absolutely refuse to do this this
is not feasible for me a lazy person
doing this in my free time so what is
the actual architecture of ggirl
it is a shamelessly monolithic shiny app
which is to say despite that there being
all this art infrastructure around
handling post requests with plumber and
shiny apps i just put it all in one big
shiny app um i i am shameless in doing
this in the sense that like if you talk
to like modern software developers like
the correct way to do things is the
micro services and a micro service says
split off little apps for each different
tasks you want to do and decouple them
i don't want to do that because i'm lazy
and maintaining a lot of things a lot of
work and i don't want to do it
i just want one shiny app and there are
actually a few reasons for this
so this is bad architecture but i think
it's actually good and here's why
one is it makes it very easy to deploy
by having just one shiny app that
handles this entire process i don't have
to worry about um
well the plumber app hasn't updated yet
but the shiny app has and now they're
out of sync like i just don't have to
worry about any of that junk um also is
actually a surprising hassle to employ
shiny apps and plumber apps the same
place so like the shiny server linux
server
doesn't support plumbers so if you want
to use shiny server on linux you can't
use plumber if you want to use shiny
apps io you can't use plumber if you
want to use google cloud run which is
amazing for deploying plumber i've had
real difficulty getting shiny to work on
that one although other people i think
have successfully done it i just haven't
um and then my shiny apps to io account
i'm in the free account and shiny at
apps.i o is great but you only get free
through or you only get five apps at any
given time and like i just described
five and my five shiny apps.i o apps i
do a lot of shiny development those
things are precious i'm not just gonna
give them all up
i really just don't want to use all of
my apps in this one thing on the shiny
offset io so i really just want one
single shine you have to do everything
which is to say that i talked a lot
about how great polymer is and it is
great but i actually didn't end up using
it for any of the development of ggirl
even though it feels like i should have
um so it's a little bit of a red herring
for a talk but hey it's thursday night
before
a long weekend who cares conference
rules i'm just gonna talk about whatever
even though i didn't use it
cool okay so
given that how would one make a single
monolithic shiny app for an entire
ecommerce platform so if you look at
that last chart like there's a ton of
things going on we're passing data to
shiny shiny is passing it to stripe
stripes facing it back we're passing it
to the postcard service that's a lot how
do we do it in one monolithic platform
well
you do it one bite at a time um i wish i
had a more clever
um analogy there um
but let's start going through one piece
by piece on how i actually did this so
the first complexity is how do you
actually pass the plot from r on a
computer to a shiny app
um which is to say when you're running r
code and you say okay take this plot and
show it to me on a web page on a server
that's running somewhere else how do i
do that with r and shiny
um
i thought this would have been really
easy and a common thing to do i just i
don't know naively assumed that all the
time people were running our code that
would then pass data to a shiny app that
was running i found almost nothing on
this like almost no one is out there
doing this usually if a shiny app needs
data that is loaded from a database or
you upload it via a button but rare is
it that an r script that is actively
running will send data to an actively
running shiny server
um and in particular i just want to pass
it a png image of what the postcard
looks like and then a bunch of stuff
happens um
and the right way to do this is with a
post request so an http post request of
i'm going to the url of the shiny server
with this image to post it to so i'm
posting that image and then i get
response back of something
shiny does not built in have that
functionality but it really should have
that in a very open documented thing
because that's important for modern
frameworks and shiny is a good framework
and it deserves that um
and in particular let me just again walk
through the steps here because i think
it is a little tricky and these steps
come up in other places too which is
that r code running on the computer
when i call that gg postcard function
what it's going to do is it's going to
send a post request with the image
to my like ggirl art upload url so it's
going to post that url this image and
then the shiny app is going to be like
okay cool got the image i'm going to
save it somewhere and then i'm going to
return
the id of what that image like a
randomly generated id for that image
and then i'll be like okay cool thanks
for the id i'm now going to i'm not
going to do a get request in the browser
or i'm going to have the user go to the
the website gjrl art preview slash this
id and then when they open the browser
window to there they will see that image
preview with the image and the like
text and stuff so it's a it's a back and
forth a couple times to send the image
get the id back then send the go view it
on shiny
so there's no documented way to do post
requests like officially but there are a
number of undocumented ways to do this
which i will now enumerate
so first undocumented shiny post hack
one
is um
there's something called the
shiny.http.response.filter
option for a shiny app that lets you
filter requests so this came to me from
garrick adam we um
and what you do is you you set in your
options this is global options not shiny
but you set in your global options for r
the
shiny.http.response.filter of a post
handler function and then in that
function
you can say well if the request is a
post do something special so the idea is
shiny has a back end way to say before
even shiny sees a request
do some special filtering function where
you do special stuff on it and then pass
the request to shiny so if you want to
do something like save the image url or
these the image to a server and stuff
like that you could do it in this post
answer
um i think this works i think it is neat
i think it is weird that this is not
documented and i
i don't know it seemed okay but this is
a good good solution
um
undocumented shiny post hack too so i
actually gave a much abridged version of
this talk um a couple of months ago at
cascadia r conf and joe chang who is one
of the other speakers there he was like
you know and also a
leading developer on shiny is that oh oh
oh actually there is another
undocumented way to do this which is the
newer versions of shiny have in the ui
component
you can actually in your ui you can have
like an if this is a post request do
something special so if the request is
method post then do your like saving the
image to the server business um and then
you have to set an attribute on the ui
for http method supported get and post
and then this works this i think is
perhaps slightly more elegant than hack
one
but this is i would know have no idea
how anyone would have ever known about
this unless they also gave a talk at a
conference and had a leading developer
watch them and submit a you know a gist
on twitter about it um so
like that it exists i wish it was a
little more documented but i didn't go
with this one either what did i actually
go with
so hack three is the new brochure
package so this is an experimental
package from colin fay and it actually
lets you do a number of really cool and
helpful for me shiny things so one is if
you have like three shiny apps like
let's say you have um i don't know
something about postcards something
about watercolors and something about
art prints you can have those three
shiny apps all roll into one app and
each one have a different endpoint so
one app runs if you go to like the
server name slash watercolor and one go
runs if you do slash art print slash
whatever so this solves my problem of i
want a bunch of apps running on within
one app
on different endpoints this handles that
another thing those endpoints don't
actually have to be shiny apps they can
also be post handlers so one of the
things in brochure could be slash upload
and what if you post request to slash
upload what it can then do is just save
that file somewhere and then send the
response with the id which is exactly
what i want to do
um so this solves two of the problems i
had which is fantastic and like i just
have to be tweeting about this he's like
oh try brochure and i'm like this is
exactly what i want um it is available
uh
i will note that it is so new it doesn't
even have a hex sticker yet which is a
sign that it is very new and
experimental and also the very first
text on this is this is a work in
progress do not use and i decided to use
it in production for a service that
handles money
um i actually had no problems with it i
think it worked nearly flawlessly i had
well i had exactly one bug i hit which
was very easy to work around and i
assume is being fixed at some point in
the future but like i love this package
i i really hope that like rose and
thrives and like this maybe even becomes
a core part of shiny because i just
think it's fantastic
[Music]
um
okay so then what is the final post
request that ends up happening in this
so the ggirl package what it will do is
it will do a post request that gets
listened to by brochure it sends what
type of medium it is postcard art print
watercolor the message if it's a
postcard the address to mail this thing
to um which could be multiple for
postcards because you can send them at
once the png image that has been
correctly sized for like a postcard or a
water print or a water art printer
watercolor and then also the package
version that's running locally because
if it turns out you're running a really
old version of ggirl client i don't want
there to be an issue where the new
server doesn't know how to handle it
um just note i do send the png of the
picture as like raw binary data
in the post request i originally toyed
with the idea of actually passing
instead of the
png image like actually just passing the
um ggplot object because then you could
like rearrange it and resize it on the
server
but the problem with this is
that would require that any package you
use to make the gg plot like any weird
like gg text or other things
would also have to be on the server for
it to be able to render that correctly
and there's no way i could have managed
that so instead i just accepted that i
will turn it into a png on the client
side and then send it to the server
um
but because of this because we are now
passing a png image not a
not a girl pl or gg plot 2 plot
it's possible we could set any type of
image right so long as the image is the
correct size i could turn anything into
a postcard including packages that are
not gg plot packages like ray shaders
which are really cool but this package
isn't called our plots in real life or
our art in real life it's called gigi
plot in real life and so for the morals
of what i was trying to build i did not
choose to include generic upload any
image as postcards or watercolors or art
prints um i don't know maybe someone
convinced me to do otherwise in the
future
um
so when the server receives the request
it generates a unique id saying here's
the id of that image you just passed me
it's like a uuid that's like 30 digit
hexadecimal whatever it saves that image
to google cloud storage so it can just
always forever be used throughout this
flow
and i don't have to worry about like
what if the server crashes or things
like that like it's always in the cloud
we're good and then sends that id back
to the gjrl plot and then girl uh sorry
the dgr package now the g irl package
then sends the user to the url of in
this case for a postcard it's the app
url postcard and the token of whatever
that id is and that produces the correct
image
[Music]
okay
so we got a server
that has the image stored in the cloud
ready to view and then the user goes to
that url to view it
what happens next how do we actually
show the preview page and then get them
to strike
so this is just
a simple fairly straightforward shiny
page
um there's not like a ton of like clever
things happening here
um um
a couple things that were important so
one is i really want these previews to
look exactly like what you're going to
get on the postcard which means like i
have to be careful with things like the
margin on the plot um oftentimes the
printers will cut off the very edges of
your plot so i had to like add a little
extra white buffer to make sure that um
the plot looked correctly and as a lot
of people here probably know gg plot is
not easy where if you change the
resolution of the image then like the
the font sizes can change and things
won't look exactly right so i just
needed to make sure there wasn't a
scenario where the font would like the
font would look very nice on this image
but then when we send it to you the
font's too big or doesn't render
correctly things like that
um but the only actual interactivity on
this whole page is that green button you
just click
pay and submit
um i also i like my shiny apps to look
nice so i use a package called boot or i
use a function a framework called
bootstrap so bootstrap is a css
framework to make web pages look
responsive so they change on mobile and
stuff and look good um
the cool thing is is that shiny is built
around bootstrap so if you start to
learn bootstrap a little bit you can
very easily use it with shiny the bad
news is shiny uses bootstraps three
which is six years old and that's like
so old that is a thousand years in um
web development um
we are now in bootstrap five we are like
two major additions past three um
but the good news is is our studio made
a package to get around this and if you
use bslib you can set it to use the most
modern versions of bootstrap i have a
whole blog post about how to make shiny
apps look good on mobile which is really
just an introduction to bootstrap for
shiny um i highly recommend you check it
out and so what i did was i used
bootstrap on this thing and i just set
the theme to be the bootswatch theme
minty and then i edited some variables
um
just that's a good blog post
um just a little bit more detail around
this page um so like for the column
sizing i use bootstrap grid
functionality which is good to check out
um we have this one button this table i
used the gt table um the gt package to
make the table look nice i added the
margin with the magic package to just
add a white set number of pixels around
it
and then for that shadow i added a
couple lines of css to the app that just
for this particular size thing you for
this particular class of picture add a
drop shadow add a little black border um
i will say though originally in the
versions the earliest versions of this
app would actually not just show you a
picture of the front right see there's a
picture font like why not actually show
the back too and like have a little logo
of djirl logo on it and like why not do
that on the postcards instead of just
having a table
well it turns out it's super annoying to
do this um for a number of reasons right
because like you really want to get the
back right right like what happens if
someone has a long word that's so long
this one long word would go over into
the address field of the postcard and
ruin it what happens then what happens
if you have so much text it gets to the
end of the the postcard um what happens
if your your text has new lines in it
and then what
this was profoundly annoying like this
is by far the most maybe not by far the
most annoying this is one of the most
annoying things of making this um so
originally the first idea i tried was i
used i figured you know what i'm making
the front with gg plot what if we made
the box a gg plot two
make the fact that ggplot2 that's a gg
pun um
so for the idea one was actually used as
a package called ggfit text where i
could say like hey make this box in the
plot i'll have text in it and have it
correctly wrap and this was decent but
it's kind of ugly like it wasn't that
pretty
um and so then idea two was i for other
reasons i switched to a printer a new
printer and then that new printer you
don't even send them a back you just
send them what text you want on the
postcard and then the printer will make
the back for you but that printer had
its own set of problems and also this is
problematic because i couldn't then
renter the back because i only would
know what the back went like would look
like when i submitted the order so i
couldn't show the back
and then the last situation the one i
ultimately went with the printer
actually asked for an html file for the
back and this is actually really
convenient because html has lots of good
things to handle like text wrapping and
stuff like that but then i had to figure
out how to take the html page and render
it within my shiny app and i decided i
just didn't care anymore so i instead
went with gt tables to show this data
but even here it still was problematic
to try and like
well what if there's a new line in there
what what if a person submits a
character that is itself a markdown
character and then gt thinks that's
marked out it was just intensely
frustrating um which you wouldn't have
expected from this very small part of
the app
okay so then how do you pass the user
from shiny to stripe right how does that
green button work that when you press
the button it starts a shiny or a stripe
order
um i would say overall the stripe app
was surprisingly easy to use for the
longest time as a data scientist i'm
like i could never handle financial
transaction that's software developer
stuff i'm just a data scientist but at
the end of the day these are still just
http post requests
um so the way stripe has you do it is
first in your
server like on your shiny server they
have you send to you post to stripe what
the shopping cart is of a person and
then stripe sends back you to you an id
of that shopping cart and then you
redirect the user to a url based on that
id which is exactly the same thing i did
with the picture stuff in the first
earlier part of this talk stripe does it
with shopping carts so you send the
shopping cart it sends you the id you
send the user to the url based on that
so to create the shopping cart or the
stripe session from shiny this is just a
very particularly formatted post request
um
when you hit that pan submit button in
shiny it sends that post request to the
server
um i have a full working example of that
button in the repo ggirl example so if
this is a part of this tutorial this
talk that interests you you can actually
go make one of these yourselves fairly
easily using that repo
um but basically i just made a function
that you gave me the attributes of the
order and then i did a post request to
stripe's thing i put in my credentials
so stripe knew this is a real order and
then
stripe would respond with the id
which i would then use to direct the
user um to actually direct the user
based on that id there has to be a tiny
bit of javascript run from stripe and so
this is really just like two lines um so
we're one in the top of the shiny app in
the head i added the script of load
chinese javascript or load strips
javascript and then it also added a
second script of if you press that
button at the end of the pressing the
button step run the stripe javascript of
redirect that person to check out so
basically stripe is handling direct to
checkout i just pass the java stripe
javascript an id and i'm saying the word
javascript a lot i'm terrified of
javascript i'm a data scientist i don't
have to deal with this stuff but like
really it was two lines i had to copy
and paste into my shiny app i did not
really touch javascript or had to reason
about javascript at all and it just
worked
[Music]
um
so then how do you fulfill the order
um
so once stripe gets money from a user
how do we make a postcard and an email
happen
um so again we're still sending post
requests so the idea is that stripe is
then going to send a post request to
shinee
and then shinee will do the stuff to
order the postcards
so this is this is this is a situation
where i'm not sending postgres or stripe
straight to sending a post request to me
that is called a web hook if you see
software developers talk about something
called a web hook that just means
instead of you sending post requests to
the api the api sends a post request to
you
um
stripe gives a little bit of guidance on
how do you make how do you put in
security checks to make sure that the
post request coming to you is real and
from stripe and not from a nefarious our
user trying to get free postcards but i
don't know that wasn't too crazy to um
set up
um
so then
um once shiny gets that notification
saying hey someone paid their money
shinee will then send a post request to
the company that prints the postcards
and shiny will send an email to the user
saying your order is confirmed this
feels like it should be straightforward
that looks like it's fairly
straightforward and it would be fairly
straightforward except for one glaring
problem
which is that stripe wants a fast
response here so when stripe sends a
post request to me in shiny
they send a post request and they leave
that connection open until you respond
yeah we got it we'll put that order in
and
if it you know it might take a few
seconds for shiny to then query the
postcard thing and then send the email
and actually while shiny's doing all
this computation everything on the shiny
server is stopped because shiny is
single threaded so like
stripe is just waiting and if stripe
waits more than a second or two it
doesn't get a response stripe is a very
anxious api and stripes just says oh you
didn't respond we're gonna assume you
didn't get that order and that kind of
makes sense because you don't want
stripe stripe doesn't want to be like
failing to tell people that they got
paid and then causing all sorts of
ruckus so if shiny doesn't
or sorry if stripe doesn't hear that you
received their order then they'll say
okay i assumed this was a failure and
i'm going to try in like 10 or seconds
or a minute i will try again to put that
order in and get a response
and again shiny won't respond until the
actual work of putting in the orders
done and so the result of this and if
you're a i don't know naive data science
um
developing your free time you may not
put a check in to avoid sending letting
users make order duplicate things over
and over and so the result is that
stripe will keep hitting your api with
the same request and china would be like
cool i'm getting all these cadets i'm
going to fill these orders but
straight's going to be like well you're
not getting back to us fast enough so
we're assuming these are all failures
and you get this
a wave of postcards being ordered
now i will say in reality the number of
postcards that i accidentally got sent
to myself was not as much as on this
page
but i will also say that in the
development of this ape or of this app i
ordered so many postcards that by the
end i was opening my mail i'd be like
ugh mail from me again and just chunk it
in the box and like i was spamming
myself and i hit that moment of
realization of like oh my god what have
i come to um
so the hacky solution would just be like
you know what i don't care if stripe
keeps sending me the same request over
and over if after the first one i'm just
gonna ignore them but
for some reason at this point in the
developing the app i have standards and
i'm not gonna let
this be the the hacky thing i do
suddenly i care about not doing hacky
stuff but more importantly they keep
emailing you if your requests fail and i
don't like it when i get annoying emails
i'm like all right fine i'll just fix
the problem um but the fix is actually
pretty cool
so what i had to do was i had to make it
so that when shiny fulfills the order
that happens in the background so shiny
gets the request from stripe
shiny just immediately checks if it's a
duplicate either way it immediately
responds or it's if it is not a
duplicate it will kick off a process a
separate r process to do the ordering
and then because that's a whole separate
process
this process would be the main one will
be like well i did all the work i need
to i kicked off that other thing and i
can respond with the success
so in practice i am no longer blocking
shiny by the actual work of putting the
order i call a new process to do that
and have shiny response success
um this is based on a github solution i
saw to a plumber problem by barrett
slurk his solution to like some github
issue um i i like this so much i wrote a
whole blog post about it but what you do
is you use the caller package to spawn
the background process and so in your
shiny server when this event happens
what you do is you're like well if this
is a new task i haven't seen this order
or whatever before i will then create a
job for
running the actual task and add it to
this list of jobs that i have running um
this ends up being really cool there's
way more applications than just ordering
postcards for the ability for shiny apps
to quickly spawn background processes
that unblock things i i think some of
the stuff is starting to get built into
shiny or into plumber it might be built
into shiny now too and i just didn't
know how to use it but like this is
great and i highly recommend that if
you're doing stuff in shiny where you
have a long-running thing that you just
want to have it happen in the background
you check out the solution because it
might help you
um okay but how do you actually order
the postcards well it turns out there
are many many many many companies out
there that will take your money and then
well there are a lot of companies i'll
take your money but we'll take your
money in exchange for having them host
an api that when you send a post request
to that api they will then mail a
postcard of it for you there are so many
of these because primarily these are
used by companies to spam your mailbox
with ads right if you're a company and i
want to send out 50 000 uh postcards and
if you want a different postcard with
like a custom message on each user it's
great to have an api you can just hit
and pass it like you know hit 50 000
times and get all those postcards sent
um
the basic idea is again you just make a
post request but in that post request is
like the image on the postcard the
address you send to the message whatever
but they very dramatically on
implementation right some want an image
for the back and some want text that
they will turn into an image for what
the message is some let you order for 10
people at once some peop some of them
don't some of them have price minimums
and i there's no way i'm gonna pay a
monthly cost to to maintain the server
this service which i have no idea how
much people are gonna use that um or and
like how quickly is the turnaround time
um
so they all do this idea of using an
image they send a postcard but like the
actual it took me a while of
experimenting before i found one i
actually liked um
and i will say this was immensely
frustrating i think this maybe was the
worst part of developing because i had
so many companies that would send
postcards and so many of them were
terrible um one of them that i almost
liked and went with um is this image on
the right i'm just getting mad looking
at it so if you look on your screen
you're like wow it's hard to read that
image because zoom's compressing it no
that's not zoom this is actually what
the postcard looked like it was like it
looked like your grandparents sent you a
facebook image and then like they copied
and pasted it into an email like it
looks so bad and it was a physical
object and
the thing was that i later learned that
these api services they don't just have
one printer they always use they often
have different printers that they just
randomly send your postcards to so like
with this one like the first five
postcards i ordered from them were great
and then suddenly the sixth and seventh
were this super ugly gross facebook
spam
thing
look and the
worst part of all was there was a
two-week turnaround time for almost any
of these services between when i sent
the image and when the postcard got in
the mail so like this
this product was delayed by months just
by trying to get the right postcard uh
service
and for some reason i have really high
standards for my hypothetical customers
who haven't even purchased these
postcards yet but i really want people
if you're getting artists stuff for the
art to look good um eventually i found
one that i liked well enough um but even
they had problems which was i was gonna
originally have these postcards be
international but for some reason the
service when i shipped postcards
internationally they just never showed
up so i didn't formally publish that um
just writing the slide gets me mad and
now reading this makes me mad because of
how much time i put into this um
so it was a real struggle and i uh yeah
it didn't didn't feel great um but in
the end i got when i'm more less late
then to send the confirmation emails i
used the r package blastula from i think
rstudio it was really easy to send these
emails it was really fantastic
one important thing though was that
i both wanted to send an email to the
user but also it was a good catch for me
so i could get an email confirmation
every time an aurora was put in and if
there was an error for whatever reason i
will want the i would want to get an
email with the error because like if it
just showed up in the shiny logs i might
not notice it and with some of these
threads being spawned if like a spawn
thread from shiny has an error that
doesn't even make it into the shiny logs
because it's in a whole separate thread
so it was really important that i have
emails to tell me when their errors and
then i realized that sometimes the
emails themselves had errors so i needed
to have an email that was just the email
itself had an error the error email had
an error and there's like a cascading
nut sequence um but all that's done in
the background and eventually all got
pretty stable to the point that that
always generally worked
um for the email content the images in
there one other thing is especially with
the postcards but even more so with like
the posters and stuff those images could
be massive they could be like you know
three you know even like 30 000 pixels
wide like they could be enormous and i
can't just put those into emails so i
had to resize them and stuff so again
the image magic package was really
helpful for this stuff
um and again the back of the postcard
was very frustrating because like if i
put the text on the back sometimes the
email like the blastula stuff if i
wasn't careful would like mess up the
new line characters or like the markdown
symbols would be red so like that was
just a lot of work too
okay so then how do i deploy it
so this is all hosted on shiny apps io
so when i originally launched the first
version of the app which just started
with postcards i paid for a month of
shiny apps at i o just in case i got so
much load that things were breaking but
it was totally fine with the base level
like there actually isn't very much load
being put on the server by the tasks you
are doing with it so i stopped paying
that was the one month i ever paid for
shiny apps at i o it was a great month
but uh sorry uh our ceo um so it's
really easy it's really cheap so now it
cost me nothing because i'm still using
the free version
um but what i also did is throughout my
code i put in the environmental vary the
environment variable gg irl deploy
environment to know if i was endeavor
prod and so throughout my thing like the
email that gets sent the
the way that i take the payments all of
them differ based on whether i'm
endeavor prod um and actually in shiny
apps io i constantly have two apps i
have the real one that people can use
and the dev one for just testing what i
showed you at the beginning of this talk
was the dev one but when you go and use
the app if you go with ggirl you will go
use the prod one um this is nice because
i could test things in dev and make sure
i liked it i could send post
hypothetical fake postcards without um
without taking payments to myself or
actually
paying for the postcards although i
didn't also would test and prod just to
make sure things work too
um and then i made these functions for
every time i want to deploy to
production deploy to dev deploy locally
and i would just run the function to do
the deployment and that made things a
lot easier um and then lastly i ran beta
tests with like real humans and i had
them test things and i ran surveys to
see what people thought and this was
also mentally helpful because it both um
helped me catch a few bugs and also
there's some functions uh features i
didn't realize i necessarily would have
wanted and then they pointed it out i'm
like okay sure i'll throw that on
um
so that was mostly about postcards let's
talk about the differences the ggr print
and gg watercolor
so for ggr print
um there are a couple changes one is
there are more formats that the user can
specify within r so they can specify if
they want the plot to be a portrait or
landscape or how big and so that image
had to be sent or that information had
to be sent with the original post um i
also like this is art prints these are
going on your wall this is important
stuff so i really wanted them to look
nice and one thing you can do to make an
image look nice is you can do
anti-aliasing which makes things look
less pixelated but um
the cairo package is typically what i
use for anti-aliasing but i turned out i
didn't even like the anti-aliasing
enough for this so i switched to rag
which was much better for anti-aliasing
but the point is is that unlike the
postcards for the art prints and
ultimately the watercolors
when you are rendering it on the client
side like in r when it's turning into a
png it uses an extra package to make
sure it looks extra pretty
and um
this meant that my package on the client
side like when you install it it has to
install rag like it has an additional
dependency and i really tried to keep
dependencies out but for this one it was
worth it
um
i tried to keep them out because i
worried the more dependencies it had the
more likely i would accidentally crap
conflict with whatever your weird stuff
you're doing in your plots and i really
want to avoid that um and then i had to
like i had to use image magic to make
the image smaller because it would be
far too big to render on a html page and
then i had to use css to make this
beautiful frame with like a nice shadow
in there so it looks like actually
actually it was important that i put a
lot of work in to make this look like a
picture and not just like like like like
a physical picture and not just look
like like your you know our studio
rendering um and i decided that was
important
so for the fulfillment what i ended up
doing is i went with the um the same
printer that i use for the art prints
that i make like of my actual watercolor
and gouache art that you can get in the
auction or if you want to buy it on my
etsy store you can go to shop at
janelles.com and support me or you can
buy the original of some of my art at
the art auction anyways there is some
shameless promotion this is a very
capitalistic talk um
but anyway so that printing service they
do have a website for doing the printing
and i could have automated that i could
have used like the selenium framework
and i think they have an r package too
to make it so that when someone places
an order it automatically like clicks
the buttons on the website and submits
the order um i chose not to do this for
two reasons one
i think that would have taken like 20
hours to code up and it would not have
taken me 20 hours to fulfill all
hypothetical orders for the entire
lifespan of this future package like
there's just no way it would ever take
that long of work because it only takes
me like three minutes to press the
button to put in the order
um and then two there is actually a nice
human in the loop thing where if someone
puts in the the order for the plot and
there's something in it that looks like
a glaring mistake i can try and catch it
before it gets um before it gets ordered
um which has happened before so that
ended up just being nice and there at
the bottom is that classic xkcd thing of
like amount of time it takes you to
automate a task which is how often you
do it whether or not you and like it is
so far off this chart how much would be
worth it to automate the step of
actually placing the order of the art
prints
uh for the watercolor the changes the
only major change from the watercolor is
no when you press the the purchase
button it doesn't actually tend you to
stripe anymore because i don't want to
take your money until i know how
complicated it's going to be to paint
the picture for you so instead what is
it does is it just sends the
confirmation email to you and sends an
email to me the artist letting me know
hey contact this person with what you
think the price code is and then we can
do the exchange on venmo um so i use
shiny's modal so that when you press
request commission it
starts the like emailing order and then
it pops up this shiny modal saying hey
your quest is submitted got it and then
it it stops the button so you can't like
just keep pressing it over and over and
send me a hundred emails
um and so i i've never used shiny modals
before but it was pretty seamless and i
was pretty happy with it
to fulfill the gg watercolors i just
paint it
with watercolors those watercolors right
there that photo was taken on the table
right there like five minutes before
this talk because i wanted to spice up
the slide um
cool so uh to wrap it up uh ggirl it's a
cool package you can order stuff via
our package um there were a fair number
of fixly bits here but like the core of
this is really just a lot of post
requests
you
um
you have brochure to handle all of the
like all the different shiny and post
requests at once and then you bounce an
art you know you're our client when you
run when you actually create your plot
it sends a post request to shiny shiny
sends a post request to stripe stripe
send the post request back to shiny
shiny sends a post request to the
postcard people
um you then use collar in the background
to avoid scenarios where shiny lagging
can cause problems in that flow and i
deployed to shiny app.io with devonprod
versions to test it and actually run it
um and i am so proud to say that i think
in the last month or two i have actually
broken even and all of the and all the
actual substantial development costs i
put into making this have now broken
even so i have not actively lost money
assuming my time is free
um
which i didn't think i would ever do so
this is a very exciting achievement for
me um so in conclusion thank you for
coming in my talk you can see the slides
at link.js.com
ggrl.com you can order your own
postcards art friends and watercolors
today right now with that r command to
install the ggirl package for you and if
you want to buy my art you can go to
shop.jnoles.com
or you can
make a bid at the uh
the r auction
and that's my
talk
thank you very much that was a another
classic jaclyn talk full of energy and
excitement i just that was really really
great so first you know golf clap
because that's the best we can do right
now
so thank you for uh for that wonderful
talk i really enjoyed that
uh some of you may have noticed the uh
paint one of the paintings jacqueline
showed in her presentation is right
there behind me
so um i'm not this is not dog food
that's not the right word but i've
already bought into the artist
it's already cool stuff and i love that
thing my wife got that for me and i'm
just in love with that painting so
everyone go to go to what shop.jnows or
janelles.com.js.com yeah thank you do
that if you want the excel david goliath
bid on at the art auction
cool
let's have a few questions
we are going to dive into those um let's
see well all right uh a question that
you answered do you shift to canada and
it sounds like no because that's
international
i've
i probably
if i put effort into it could
make my at least the art prince and
watercolors ship to canada if you want
those things and you in canada just send
me an email the postcards i suspect i
will never get to just because the
postcard sending companies are so
dubious quality but for the art prince
of watercolors um email me if you are
interested
great so for that there we know that
um
you said that
you had the correct architecture and
then you didn't answer this but the
person asked the question
uh how do you go about planning a
correct architecture and what's an
example of an incorrect but reasonable
architecture a noob would make
so i think
you sort of answered that yeah i don't
think there's a real truth to this i
think there's a there's like a certain i
think there's like paradigms in software
development which is the more you like
make things into one giant
software piece of software the harder
things are developed and like you hear a
lot about like modern like software
companies like microsoft you know with
their like office or whatever it's like
one so big piece of code that it's like
almost impossible to add on to and so
the idea is if you split things into
smaller it gets better but sometimes you
can split things so small that the cost
of it's easier to write code but it's
harder to deploy and it's harder to keep
them all in sync and so i kind of was
tongue-in-cheek saying that like the
correct architectures that have a whole
bunch of plum wraps and things like that
i think in practice there's not really a
true right answer and like i think that
like companies hire architects because
they're people who sit around all day
trying to weigh the benefits of
different architectures versus the cost
of these um
i do think if this was if this is going
to get like 10 times more traffic i
would maybe switch to that like five
app system but given the amount of
traffic this thing actually gets it's
probably fine the way it is
should each function be an api call for
a microservice that seems a little
overkill yeah that's right yeah
uh you talked about brochure is that
sort of like modules on steroids
okay so i have a confession which is i
do so much shiny development i've almost
never handled modules or done modules i
my understanding actually i don't even
know enough about modules to say this
but i will just shameless or i will
shamefully say that despite being a
pretty reasonable shiny developer i just
never use my but like i will also say
that like
i think shiny modules my understanding
of modules is they are one approach to
handle the fact that if you have a super
complicated shiny app where each widget
affects all the other widgets like
modules can make it simpler i think
brochure is like a parallel approach of
like what if you had separate apps for
each component of what you're doing and
maybe you have a little bit of stuff
shared um but maybe that's all i want to
say because i don't know enough about
this to say something smart
i asked that personally because
i am i've worked on this app that's
really complicated i made like
completely separate apps and i just said
okay i make an entire app into a module
and stick that into an app essentially
an app of modules so it sounds like
brochure is doing a similar similar
thing
i could see that it's also like
i used to use this linux shiny server
like the free version like you just spin
up a shiny server and you can like run
10 apps on that um which is kind of like
what brochure does but brochure actually
lets you pass things between the apps a
little more and also like chinese server
isn't super supported by r anymore so or
our studio anymore so like it's just not
easy to use
yeah that's actually a great book so
that you answered my second question was
like does it pass up back and forth
answered yes perfect
yes although actually i will say my apps
very much don't very much most of what
gets passed is in the actual request
itself like the post request will send
the id and things like that and i
originally did have stuff being passed
between the different things like i had
a set of memory for all the different
components that got shared and i just
got so worried i'm like well what if i
have three apps running in parallel
because i have so much load or what if
one of the servers crashes or things
like that i'm like it's just better to
the moment i get any data save it to the
google cloud and then just always be
pushing and pulling from that because
that's easy and cheap
now when you say save to google cloud do
you talk are you talking about like a
google drive are you talking more about
like a bucket situation yet i am talking
about a bucket situation i use
specifically google cloud storage and
there's a package called google cloud
storage r i find the package somewhat
complicated to set up the credentials
for but once you set those credentials
up it is very easy to like just like aws
s3 is equivalent to this i just save it
to a bucket and then pull it from a
bucket when you need it and i saved it
by the id like the unique hash of each
of the different
pictures
nice i was just going to say because aws
s3 is hard to set up but once you do
just sort of just pull that yeah yeah
yeah
uh we have a question i'm gonna go a
little bit out of order because like
apparently zoom you can't copy and paste
from the chat so i had to manually type
in the questions so this was staring at
me i'll just ask it um since it started
as a personal project can you describe
how your time management process evolved
once things started getting serious
oh that's a really good question so what
it was was like
it was like two or three months of just
idly thinking about like well what if it
was like a thing you ordered watercolors
from what if i asked you to send you'd
me a venmo payment what if you'd
and then like i did just have this
moment where like i was talking to
heather i think emily um robinson a
little bit about this too and i'll just
clicked and i'm like okay i feel like i
now see the approach and then i coulda
coded real fast and i hit this point
where like it was actually kind of
interesting that the fact that i
couldn't actually get the postcards yet
kind of limited me like because like if
i can't see how they look i kind of
can't do that much more development um
but i will say that it kind of got
progressively like a stupid and stupider
like it was taking all my time and just
like but it was so fascinating and like
like especially with like the rendering
the back there were so many angles i
could do to make it prettier like i want
to make sure the code gets like the id
gets sent to the email in case you have
a problem you can set it back but like
should i send the whole code it's easier
to just only said eight digits but and
like i got like i got way too deep in it
and it got really bad and then i
released the poke postcard part everyone
liked it and then like got like a break
and then it did like a little bit again
for the watercolor or the art print i
got a little break so like i kind of
paced after that but the first part was
not a healthy use of my time by the end
but a fun use at least oh yeah no this
is super fun this is one of maybe the
most it was it was kind of i think the
most intriguing product i've ever worked
on like i think it is the most like like
well encapsulated it does like tons of
different stuff it's got things it's got
dev and prod and support email address
like it is the most it is the most
well-rounded personal project i've ever
done
nice that's awesome
that's really awesome
that's cool um
for your drop shadows did you check if
edward tufte is okay if that
um okay is he i hope he's not watching
this recording but i'm gonna say can i
i'm gonna like say some not great stuff
ah this is drop it so i very early in my
career the first year of my career i
like and my first job i got like one of
the few people from my company got to go
hear tough talk and i listen to him talk
for a day you know when you buy the four
books and i listen to talk and i'm like
this guy's so smart he knows so much i'm
gonna make all my charts way better and
like it way ingrained in me and then
only years later that i'm like this guy
is more caring about being technically
correct but like if everyone else in the
company uses powerpoint and you're there
using your garamond excel file printed
out in the 11x4 like you're not actually
working with a company and i got really
upset and i felt betrayed and resentment
that tough was too over specific and
then it started get like kind of snippy
about him and then i realized he follows
me on twitter and then i just don't try
and talk too much about tuft anymore
until right now
we got it out of you yeah
so that's a tough sucker we had a talk a
few years ago from luda um
and she had a post about how like he
talked about you can't make this stuff
an hour and everyone tweeted back him
you could do it all right you could do
it i could do an r and he started
blocking everybody including luda
yeah so i don't know what that's all
about but i do think he's overly uh
dogmatic and also like i don't know it
makes it look like a picture so i like
at the end
all right cool
um so to some of the less controversial
um
what exactly is google cloud runner you
talked about that a few times very
exciting oh yeah google lock galaga is
super cool basically okay so a docker
container is like a way to record
exactly what our version is installed
and what packages you have and what code
is in there and how do you run it
and so if you have a plumber api that
takes sends and gets requests you can
put it in a docker container and that
means i'm going to specify exactly the
correct version of r and what docker
files and what plumber api functions are
and what data is in there and all this
stuff me and heather have a lot of
material on there and i highly recommend
people check it out google cloud run is
a service that takes these docker takes
any docker container and says when you
hit an api we run that docker container
for you so if you have a plumber api you
can do like you know no or like
jknowles.com and then slash you know
jls.com that sum function from the
plumber slide and then google cloud will
receive that request be like okay spin
up the docker container with art real
fast do the math send the response and
then turn off the docker container so if
you have a plumber api it's super cheap
to use google cloud run because it only
even ever has the docker container
running in the very small moments where
people are using it um so if you do
things like docker containers um
google cloud is great for running that i
have had trouble getting shiny apps to
work in docker containers in google
cloud run but i've seen blog posts where
other people have successfully done it
so it's maybe worth checking it out but
the point is if you have our code that
needs to be like continuously listening
for either as a shiny app or um as
plumber google cloud run is a really
fantastic service for that
and so i'm assuming that it handles like
scaling all of a sudden you get 10 000
hits this api it spins up the image
multiple times yes exactly and you just
you tell it like what is the maximum
number of instances you have set up what
is the maximum number each instance can
handle at any given time if you don't
want like 10 going to the same thing
because that might break it um it's all
super good at that and like all you need
to pass it is a docker container and so
far as i know like aws has nothing as
convenient to use as that of like they
have lambdas but like big lambdas aren't
well set up for r unless you do a lot of
weird back and stuff that doesn't super
work um whereas google's like you give
us a docker container that's open to
port 8080 we will make it work for you
so
nice
and with polymer you can have multiple
endpoints you can do the same thing with
this the container you're containing
have multiple endpoints and are those
end points defined in the plumber file
or is it defined in the
google cloud runner config it's all
defined in the plumber file so all
google cloud does is any traffic to your
domain it passes to your api assuming
and it passes it to port 8080 so in your
plumber like in the file i showed i said
listen to port 80 because if your
browsers use port 80 but anyways if you
switch it to port 8080 then google will
send it to your plumber container and it
can
it will also like plumber will handle
that you are the correct url and all
that stuff and it's just it's very
seamless it's one of the easiest ways to
deploy plumber apps um i have witnessed
and where does the auth get handled by
cloud runner or by plumber by auth which
is one of the nicest part because
plumber does not have built-in
authentication nordic shiny i think and
which is
frustrating but
one thing you can do is you can build it
into docker into your docker container
you can add a layer for the auth stuff
and me and heather have documentation on
how to do that but if you use the
service like google cloud run you don't
even have to put any off at all because
google handles all that and it only
passes your docker container the traffic
that has already been authenticated
cool very cool to see
yeah
um the stripe request waiting time um
someone has is this related to
independency tokens
i don't remember what those are
i don't know i'm pronouncing
independency correctly either no i think
you're right well here's what stripe
does when stripes sends you a here's
someone who paid money what stripe
includes with you is a certain set of
tokens and you then have to take those
tokens and your secret token and decrypt
them and when you decrypt that token if
it correctly decrypts it's like yes this
correctly decrypt which means this is an
authentic thing because we only send it
to you but it also has a time in there
and if it like if it decrypts but that
time was five hours ago that means that
this request maybe it was real but
someone like copied it and they sent it
to you again five hours later and so
don't use it so you have to specify like
what is the amount of like what is the
window you're willing to tolerate in
terms of the request being um out of
date um
i don't know if that is what those are
about but that is primarily how the
stripe token stuff works okay
hope that answers the question
yeah
um so you talked about call rrbg to use
something in the background to like spin
off asynchronous is that sort of
superseded that promises package
i'm trying to remember how they relate i
think caller might be a rapper around
promises or something like that i don't
know
relation to them yeah i do think collar
is like the latest like the way most
like
our studio is currently like kind of
sharing is what i've seen okay and it's
really very convenient it's like
so and and i will say like it's kind of
i find this stuff all kind of confusing
both with shiny and color and less
because like currency means so many
different things to so many different
people because there's a lot of places
where like you do things concurrently
but you want to wait till they're all
done before you do the next step but
like this is like i literally don't care
if it takes me three hours i never care
about the result all i want to do is
fire off that end that thing to get
started and then never think about it
again and like the caller versus
promises i personally or like shiny has
built and ate i personally always am
constantly getting confused on like
which type of thing handles which type
of those concurrencies best i will say
call our
i believe caller is the same framework
that happens when you do like in our
studio and you fire off a job of like
like i think that's all related and
those are all cool functions um so
i guess i don't really have the correct
answer um but i will say that i've i've
had a lot of happiness with i want to
spawn off a whole nother thing and i
don't want it to slow me down um caller
is really good for that
all right cool
targets uses color also um to do a lot
of stuff you can do caller r color rpg
so yeah so it's they get that probably
is that the hot new way
um and then the last question i have
written down so in case anyone else
wants to jump in here um do you talk
about you have your dev and your prod of
the environment variable do they each
count as a separate app on shiny apps
that i o they do so i did decide to take
the a two out of five hit to have them
be two separate apps you could imagine
in theory i could have it be the same
app except i really like when i was
developing the watercolor stuff
that wasn't yet published so i didn't
want to have it mess with the users who
were still already using the postcards
and art prints so that was more of like
i could have had it work but then i
would have lost the like i want to be
able to do stuff and break things
without my customers having issues um
but i did have to like i remember i did
have to delete an rs app i love and i
don't remember what it was now so i
guess i didn't love it that much
you let it you let it go and it didn't
come back yeah that's right yeah and so
is that typically the way of shiny apps
you want to have like multiple let's say
the parametrized this user gets this set
of stuff this user gets that set of
stuff did to publish two completely
separate apps or is the way if an
environment variable um allows you to so
what you can do in shiny apps then a
very nice easy thing you can do is you
can in the url you can have tokens or
sorry you can have query parameters so
if you remember i had question mark
token equals blah blah blah that is a
url query parameter and
websites are constantly using them and
you will look if you go to a domain or
url you'll see at the end question mark
and then this thing goes this equals
that shiny is very easy to handle query
parameters so like if you wanted to be
able to like if you wanted
when you go to the shiny app to see the
red version you could go to like your
shiny app.com
question mark color equals red and then
that server would know
so if you want one shiny app that can do
different things for like based on which
url you go to it's not that bad but if
you want like two totally separate apps
then that doesn't really work so well
like you could have two separate apps
and like at the top of your app have an
if statement of like if the like i don't
know it's ugly and brochure kind of does
a lot of that for you so
okay
cool
all right so i think that was the last
question i was gonna check zoom i'll
check slack all right that was all of
them
so
thank you very much for that wonderful
talk uh i learned a lot because it was
just fun uh so everyone else had a fun
time and learned a lot of look just like
i did
um and we hope to see you again one of
our meetups or our conferences both
virtual and in person
and um anyone wants to see more jaclyn
stuff come check out her art auction at
the
rstats.ai oh if you want to see previous
talk she's given as part of this
community our stats that ai has a whole
video page of previous years videos i've
done at least two or three of the
conferences in the past so go check out
that stuff there of course there's other
stuff
and they're all about as zany as this
one yeah
yes indeed the zaniness is important
part of it yeah right thank you thank
you very much everyone have a great
night and i'll see a bunch of you at the
conference next week and those we will
see you around next month or future
months bye everyone bye